so I thought we'd look at today is how
do pop Adidas hardest tape store
information they all store the data but
in terms of electrical signals in
silicon but as basically magnetic data
stored on bits of spinning rust so what
I've got here is a five and a quarter
inch floppy disk this one's got a copy
of small talk on it probably for PC it's
what small talk small talk is the the
classic object-oriented programming
language then what about object-oriented
programming then look at one of our
arrow videos this is not the word saver
icon this is actually a three and a half
inch floppy disk which is what people
are probably more familiar with
essentially this and this work in
exactly the same way that's just easier
to see what's going on and why they'll
call floppy with one of these when these
are produced they put a protective hard
case around the floppy disk and a mental
cover to protect the actual floppy
information there so it's easy to see
why these are called floppies if you
actually take them apart and here's one
I destroyed earlier this is a five and a
quarter inch floppy they're also eight
inch floppies and if you actually take
it apart you'll see this is a sort of
protective plastic case there we are in
and inside that there is a sort of
material thing that's actually there to
protect the floppy disk which is this
bit so when the IBM originally created
the floppy disk they originally just had
the floppy part like that but they found
that dirt and things would scratch it
and destroy the data so they put it in a
protective case so that only the
readwrite area was exposed to protect
the data and the material side just sort
of mopped up any adjuster got in there
and stopped it scratching the data and
it is literally just a piece of plastic
coated in effectively rust is probably a
cobalt based compound rather than iron
but it's basically rust it's magnetic
data I knock so just like a classic
cassette tape or a video tape that you
may have used so what have we got well
we've got a magnetic material and the
way the computer would use this is
actually easier to see with tape so
computer tape
effectively the same sort of things is a
classic tape you may have seen these in
sort of old movies sort of sitting in
the background turning and that's
exactly what they did if we take the
casing off you have an even thinner even
floppy a piece of tape than the actual
proper disc and you can start to see why
tape is even still used today because it
just holds so much data you think about
it the amount of surface area that you
can write to on a floppy disk is only
going to be a small amount of tape that
you need to store the same thing and yet
if you think about the size of this you
can get a lot more tape into the same
area well that's someone else do the
math on that so you have the tape and
you have one side of it got all your
data on and another one going to the
take-up spool just like an old
reel-to-reel audio cassette and then you
would have a head and I'm going to use
the pen to represent the head of the
machine which would sit in contact with
the tape and the tape would be pulled
across the head as it was transferred
from one spool to the other and that
head could either read the data that was
on the tape or write the date on the
tape and how is actually arranged
depends on the tape format we won't go
into the details but you could basically
store bits of information sequentially
on the tape so you start off with the
first bit here say than the next bit and
so on and as you read through the tape
you would store more and more
information as I said the order on the
actual day two depends on the tape
format this is general principle and as
you read through it you get more and
more the data was it would it be one
one-line thick or would you be using
multiple tracks there was various
different formats I mean this is nine
track tape I think I'm not entirely sure
what you sort of had nine track tape
formats you had other ones
some of them use helical scan were
actually the head is spinning itself and
so it's writing stripes across the
actual tape like a video cassette does
these various things some are linear
when they're ready writing in that
though actually it literally depends on
the tape format most common one today is
called linear tape whether it's actually
still linear I am NOT certain so you can
store a lot of information on this but
you have to access it effectively
sequentially you have to start at the
beginning and move through to the end
before you can get to any information
that you want on it which of course
takes time if you want the information
right at the end here you have to spill
out all the information on the tape
and you can do this relatively fast and
Shawn's going to wind all this back up
later so only works you have to access
things sequentially you don't have easy
random access to the data you could do
it you could get the computer to sort of
work out where how far needs to fast
forward and then put markers in the data
so you can find different bits but you
still have to wait while it gets to that
point to access it what we disk work in
roughly the same manner to record data
I've got a floppy drive here which I've
taken apart
eagle-eye viewers may recognize it you
still have the heads just here the disk
is popped in and you manually have to
close the thing down to lock the disk in
place and then there's a motor which
spins the disk ground so the disk is
spinning round and round around very
fast like a CD does so the really
important thing is that the head can
move backwards and forth over the top of
the floppy so we have two axes of
movement here we have the disk spinning
and it'll go in one direction let's go
that way
which means that the head is getting the
data in a loop so it'll get some of the
data as it goes around and round around
around and they'll come back again you
can start getting the data again but the
head can also move backwards and forward
along the dryer which means it can step
out or step in to different parts of the
disk and so get a different loop or
different trackers they're known of
information from the disk if I can draw
a circle which I can't hurry up so this
is a disk so we've got the head going up
and down which means it can draw tracks
around with this as I said I can't draw
circles just one more and so the head
can step out to each of these track and
read a different set of data at each of
these different points so protocol this
track 0 this would be track 1 this would
be tracked - this is the track 3 and
this would be tracked
4 so we've now got 5 tracks of
information where we can store data
so where's on tape we have one long
piece of information and we have to
scroll backwards and forwards in it with
a disk we have lots of small tracks of
information but the sort of consent
along the disk surface and we can step
our head to read one of these tracks and
because the disk is spinning probably
with a floppy like one of those at 300
RPM with a modern hard disk which works
in exactly the same way at 7,200 RPM we
very quickly get all the data that's
stored on their path under the head in
one go so we can specify which track we
want to read the data from and we can
move our head to the right point but we
actually go one step further because we
actually break the data up into what we
call sectors like so and then hami ok
I'm not an artist looks like a giant
spider's web it's not yeah I mean it's
the same thing you bisecting the circle
into several slices we've got 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 we have 10 sectors so we say
that the data we want to access is on
track to set to 8 and we go to track 2
and we wait as this spins around until
we get the data for sector age read
across and then we might say we actually
want the data from track for sector worn
so we wait until the data for sector 1
of track 4 comes across so if we go back
to the drive if we put the disk with our
drive on a diagram here and we eliminate
it we've got the sector's around here
the disk is spinning very very fast so
the head just moves backwards and
forwards and say so it's down there
their position for track 1 and it waits
until sector to say comes across reads
the data and then send it out to the
computer or take the data from the
computer and write it onto the floppy
and so because of that we can access any
particular sector of data we want to on
the disk because of the nature of a
circle
surely the inner tracks store less data
than the outer tracks so yes they will
or maybe they won't it depends on how
the disks formats the information a
standard sort of PC floppy the inner
track store as much data as the outer
tracks because the disk is spinning it's
not distance it's an angular velocity
not air so it's got a constant angular
velocity so it takes the same amount of
time to go around once all that means is
the data is packed into a smaller thing
but it
out at the same speed it probably means
the data is more likely to get corrupted
on the inner tracks rather than the
outer tracks on something like a five
and a quarter inch floppy probably
depending on the type would either be
storing 256 bytes maybe 512 bytes of
data in one sector of the same on a
three and a half inch floppy you'd have
512 byte sectors and actually your hard
disks work in exactly the same fashion
they have tracks they have sectors and
they also have different heads and the
other thing you get in the hard disk is
you just have multiple platters and the
reason they're called hard is because
they're made out of things like glass
rather than after flexible bits of
plastic we keep carving away at this and
what we'll end up with is something that
looks nearly like a cube so we probably
may be a bit a bit of extra there and a
bit of extra there and there but we'll
get it we're getting there okay now some
objects obviously are more amenable to
miss than others but the more images we
get the better it is